What moment triggered your obsession
with the topics outlined in the biblical
series and maps?
Well,
that's a good question.
I actually don't know the answer
that I wouldn't say it was a moment.
I know that from the time I was
about 16 till the time that I was 24,
so I had recurrent
nightmares about nuclear war.
And so that was certainly part of it.
And they were very vivid
and very realistic.
And so,
and certainly my reading
especially about the Holocaust,
um,
also and then later Solzhenitsyn's
accounts of the Gulag archipelago for
example,
the horrors there that was
also a major contributor.
Um,
it was my concern about the Cold War.
I would say that was really the
trigger in general because I wanted to
understand,
I,
I took a political science degree
first and looked at it from a political
perspective.
But most of my professors by the time
I was in my third or fourth year,
insisted that the reason
that people fought,
the reasons that people
thought were economics.
And I never did believe that because,
well,
people fight about the things they value,
but it isn't obvious like why
people value the things they value,
you know,
so it's a psychological issue as far
as I'm concerned with and know on an
economic issue.
And so it was my discomfort,
dissatisfaction with the
standard political science
viewpoint directed omic team
point combined with this strange
obsession I had about the Cold War.
Maybe that's associated to some degree
with my proclivity to depression.
I mean,
who knows?
You know,
I don't know.
Um,
I was obsessed with it and I,
it isn't obvious why things grip
you and shake you like a rat,
you know?
Um,
I guess there's something about that
that seems to be associated with what
people used to call destiny.
So,
mmm.
But it certainly wasn't an obsession when
I was 23 or 24 when I started writing
maps of meaning.
I was thinking about it 16 hours a day,
like top speed,
just nonstop.
And the only relief I could get from it,
Ruby,
was to go work out with weights,
which I did for quite a long time.
And gained about 35 pounds in about a
year and a half working out with weights.
I had to quit because
I was eating so much.
It was taking up like half my life.
So,
um,
anyways,
I don't know what it was,
you know,
who knows,
who knows what,
what darkness lurks in
the bottom of a soul.
No one,
why it's there.
Um,
maybe it was also the fact that I could
see in myself the tendencies that might
lead people to do terrible things.
Um,
and I was also very,
very curious about that.
So maybe that was an encounter with the
union shadow or something like that.
Jeremy Whole Shelf says,
will you lecture in the Netherlands?
Yes.
As a matter of fact,
I'm coming to the Netherlands
in January to lecture there.
Um,
I'll put the link to that up on my website
at some point in the relatively near
future.
So.